serge est très embêté il vient de
recevoir une mise en demeure de ses
voisins les loups gris
ils affirment qu'ils sont propriétaires
d'une partie de son père voilà
l'histoire il ya 15 ans serge offre à sa
voisine madame label son espace de
stationnement dont il n'a pas besoin la
suivante
madame label vend sa maison où le gris
qui continue de garer leurs hôtes aux
chasseurs les années passent et un jour
serge achète une auto
il avise les legris qui veut reprendre
son stationnement
les legris répondent qu'il n'en est pas
question ce stationnement leur
appartient ce que les loups gris invoque
c'est ce qu'on appelle la prescription
acquisitive en clair le code civil
permet de devenir officiellement
propriétaire d'un terrain qu'on utilise
depuis longtemps mais pour y arriver dit
le gris devront aller en cours et
prouver qu'ils étaient convaincus depuis
au moins dix ans d'être les
propriétaires du stationnement
il leur faudra aussi prouver qu'ils
n'ont pas pris possession du terrain par
la force et que tout le monde était au
courant de leur possession
la partie n'est pas gagnée une simple
entente signée dès le début entre serge
madame la belle lily legris aurait pu
éviter tout cela un voisin averti en
vaut deux